[Music]
on this Sunday night sending
reinforcements
ottawa's Children's Hospital calls in
the Red Cross as flu cases climb
prompting A desperate plea from
Frontline Physicians we've got flu shots
that are free and widely available the
cost of Christmas inflation casts a
chill on holiday shopping and donations
reform in Iran a top official claims the
country is reviewing its hijab law and
abolishing its notorious morality police
plus striking Accord
the program teaching music to children
in Vancouver's downtown east side
global national with Paul Nasser
reporting tonight Jeff Semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us this cold and flu season is packing a
punch the Children's Hospital of eastern
Ontario or Chio is now calling in the
Red Cross for support as Hospital staff
struggle to cope with a so-called
triedemic of respiratory illness
covid-19 RSV and influenza the flu has
arrived ahead of schedule with case
counts climbing to Heights not seen in
years and it's a similar story South of
the Border and across the Atlantic so
what's behind this bad flu season Ross
Lord went looking for the answer in our
top story tonight
the triple whammy of viruses is hurting
more Canadian families by the day like
Alberta Health Services discharging
respite patients from a pediatric
hospice it's moving staff to its
overwhelmed Children's Hospital a sad
situation for Leah luzier honestly my
first reaction was anger she's been
using rotary Flames house since her son
Braden was born with a rare genetic
disorder 11 years ago it means that
the people that scheduled their time to
spend there for however long it's closed
they now have
the option of
hard hit Ontario is also struggling to
adjust in a statement the Children's
Hospital of eastern Ontario says we've
responded to unprecedented volumes due
to RSV the flu and covet forcing Chio to
ask other organizations for help and
will be partnering with the Red Cross
who will have a small team of Staff
starting next week to support our
clinical teams well it's yet another
example that yeah we have a serious
issue on our hands the flu is rarely
fatal in children but it's having a
severe impact on many and it's still on
the rise Health Canada's newly posted
update shows for the week ending
November 26th there were more than ten
thousand new cases of covid nationally
more than 8 000 cases of flu and more
than 2 000 RSV detections some doctors
say pandemic measures like masking and
distancing have left immune systems more
vulnerable and you've had less of those
viruses circulating circulating uh and
less Community level protection that you
see a Resurgence of them I mean that's
epidemiologically sound is that the only
thing that's happening I'm not sure a
big contributor he says is what's not
happening getting vaccinated against
influenza very few are having the flu
shot and that's it's astounding to me
seeing how much flu we're dealing with
that people aren't really aware that
they can do something to protect
themselves against the flu some flu
clinics are only starting now more than
a month after the outbreak started as
Canada's disjointed Health Care System
tries desperately to catch up
Ross Lord Global News
and Canada isn't the only country
struggling to cope with a wave of
illnesses in the UK parents are being
warned about a spike in cases of strep a
after the deaths of seven children from
the virus in the last four months
doctors there are warning parents to be
vigilant and check for symptoms such as
rashes headaches and fever but can
become fatal if not treated properly and
respiratory illnesses are also
overwhelming the health system in the
United States fueled in part by social
Gatherings over the American
Thanksgiving weekend the flu is hitting
particularly hard with about 9 million
cases and 4 500 deaths recorded and
that's on top of a surge in cases of
covid-19 and RSV Jennifer Johnson
reports from Washington
Thanksgiving travel hit close to
pre-pandemic levels in the U.S last
month but millions of Americans are now
paying for all the close contact that
came with those holiday Gatherings with
at least 45 States reporting flu cases
at widespread or high levels there's
kind of this rebound thing where we
haven't been able to really gather
during the holidays for two years we
might kind of overdo it this year that
just increases the likelihood that that
influenza can spread easily flu
hospitalizations haven't been this high
in early December in more than a decade
cases are 20 times higher than this time
last year compounding the crisis that
shortage of children's flu medications
seen across North America as well as a
lack of Tamiflu for adults across the
U.S the situation is much like in Canada
people are getting sicker and heading to
emergency rooms that can't hold them the
combination of the high viral activity
and the lack of some of these available
remedies and treatments is creating a
worsening of this triple donut Health
Center owners here are also overwhelmed
with the flu Koba 19 and RSV cases
including in Orange County California
where hospitals have declared an
emergency status due to a lack of
pediatric beds three-month-old bricks
and Clark went into respiratory failure
after Contracting RSV he was really
really struggling to breathe after U.S
Thanksgiving covet hospitalizations
reached their highest level in three
months with more than 35 thousand
patients treated and Christmas Hanukkah
and New Year's celebrations are just
around the corner Mike plea to the
community is use common sense use the
basics about spread of viruses and try
to avoid the emergency room unless you
truly feel you have an emergency doctors
are urging Americans to get updated kova
19 and flu vaccines experts say the
pandemic has kept flu antibodies low
making millions of people more
susceptible than ever as they get set
for another busy holiday season
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
in China the easing of strict covid-19
rules is prompting a mixed reaction
in Beijing authorities carried away a
covid-19 testing Booth overnight
symbolizing the end of China's zero
covid policy that has locked citizens in
their homes and forced them to take
frequent testing with negative results
required to go almost anywhere in the
face of widespread protests authorities
are now loosening the rules China has
refused to accept western-made vaccines
relying instead on its own an
epidemiologist warned that China's
Health Care System may not be prepared
for the wave of covid infections the
country could soon face
well one infectious diseases expert who
is all too familiar with navigating a
medical crisis is Dr Anthony fauci the
top U.S health official achieved
worldwide Fame for his work during the
covid-19 pandemic and for shepherding
the rapid development of life-saving
vaccines his remarkable career has
spanned more than 50 years but in the
next few weeks he will step away from
the top job our Washington bureau chief
Jackson prosco spoke with fauci
reflecting on his career and his fears
for the future
Dr fauci you're preparing to step away
from NIH and I'm just wondering how
you're sort of feeling in these final
weeks well it's a Bittersweet feeling
because I have been at the National
Institutes of Health
for now 54 years I came as a 27 year old
newly minted physician and I'm now a
soon to be 82 year old senior person in
the biomedical research and and Global
Health establishments so I ask myself
what do I have to offer the country and
the world
yeah I have to ask as you look back on
all those decades uh in public service
is there a favorite moment a favorite
memory a favorite accomplishment that
really stands out to you I've had the
privilege of advising seven presidents
of the United States starting
with Ronald Reagan the thing that I feel
good about that a high point is that I
established a separate division to focus
predominantly on HIV AIDS at a time
when the world did not have much of
interest in HIV AIDS even though it was
insidiously creeping through the world
killing a lot of people you've been in
the public eye through all of this right
you've been in the public eye through
your work with HIV right through to your
work with covid
and I'm sort of curious what you've seen
in the changes in public discourse and
the challenges around communicating
issues of Public Health uh to Everyday
People the politization of science
where in the United States you have the
adherence or not
to very clear Public Health principles
that are influenced strongly by one's
ideology
where you should have a uniform approach
towards an acceptance of things that are
proven to be life-saving that should
never be a person should not suffer and
die because certain ideologies tell them
that they should or should not accept
the vaccine it doesn't matter what your
political ideology is
does that make you worry about what the
response to the next public health
emergency or next pandemic could look
like
the thing that keeps me up at night is
the thing that has always kept me up at
night unfortunately
that nightmare we're living through
right now is the fact that we might have
yet again another pandemic and we will
not be prepared for it if we don't learn
the lessons of what we've been through
right now
any advice for who comes next after you
at NIH
yeah I mean my advice would be to stick
with the science and follow the science
and try as best as you can to articulate
what the scientific principles are
as as as best as you possibly can so
that people could understand that and by
all means
stay out of politics
and you can watch the full interview
with Dr Anthony fauci on our website
globalnews.ca global national
this holiday season is shaping up to be
one of the most expensive Canadians have
ever faced inflation is taking a big
bite out of holiday spending boosting
the cost of meals gas home heating and
of course presence Marnie blunt has the
story
[Music]
inside the kitchen at Ottawa Mission
staff and volunteers are busier than
ever we're seeing a shocking increase in
hunger on a regular basis
and seeing major spikes in demand and
need driven in part by the pandemic and
deepened by inflation it puts a
significant financial pressure on our
shelter the Ottawa Mission says their
annual meal numbers Surge from 495 000
pre-pandemic nearly doubling to 938 000
this year and the call for holiday meals
has gone up more than five-fold this
year they expect to serve 14 000
Christmas dinners Way Beyond the usual
2500 with food costs up across the board
budgets are being blown away but as you
can imagine if food has gone up by
almost 12 percent overall
that means we have a cost overrun for
our meal program of hundreds of
thousands of dollars and with money
tight for many Charities are feeling the
pinch too if money is really tight right
now rather than canceling that monthly
charitable donation that you're giving I
cut it down so go from thirty dollars to
twenty dollars inflation impacts also
hitting small businesses a recent survey
by the retail Council of Canada shows 6
in 10 Canadians are feeling Financial
strains and plan on looking for more
deals this year this Boutique in Vernon
BC has seen a Slowdown in traffic you
can't blame people everything is just so
expensive everywhere and some are
sensing a change in spending habits
people are
buying smaller items and are bigger
ticket items are a little uh sort of a
harder sell right now
back at the Ottawa Mission the team is
committed to their cause no matter the
cost it's very unfortunate about the
price of food but we're not going to
turn anybody away this is the Bank of
Canada weighs one more potential
interest rate hike Wednesday before
closing out a year of record high
inflation with some forecasters
expecting a quarter or half Point
increase even that would bring Canada's
key lending rights to the highest it's
been since 2008. Jeff Marty blunt in
Ottawa thanks Marty
abolishing Iran's morality police
coming up the country's attorney general
Sparks hope and skepticism after
announcing potential reforms
welcome back thousands of delegates from
nearly 200 countries are gathering in
Montreal this week for the United
Nations cop-15 Summit hoping to hammer
out a once in a decade deal to preserve
biodiversity and protect the world's
ecosystems the summit comes after
countries including Canada failed to
meet the 2020 goals set out by the last
biodiversity plan 10 years ago Amanda
jelawicki has a preview
foreign
s of police officers surround a
conference center in Downtown Montreal
they've secured a large perimeter around
the building preparing for the cop-15
summit we can see that nature loss is
accelerating and that means we need to
act quicker now too okay final touches
are being put on boardrooms ready to
host on the delegation
organizers say up to 20 000 people from
185 countries are participating in the
12-day conference the goal to adopt a
new agreement protecting the world's
plants animals and ecosystems everything
from reducing pesticide use to managing
invasive species is on the table it's
extremely important I would say it's a
generational event it's defining for us
uh this year a new framework for
biodiversity a new deal for nature if
you like the ambitious goals some are
seeking an agreement to protect 30 of
the world's water and land by 2030. in
Canada 14 of the land is currently
protected
there is a difference of opinion about
the ambition and whether we'll come away
with a very strong agreement for nature
um I'm not for sure Montreal is a
last-minute stand-in for the conference
after it was moved from China because of
covet restrictions it's left Security
Forces scrambling to get ready for
expected protesters this is an event
that you know was declared a major event
only several months ago it gave us a lot
less time in the whole planning the
conference begins December 7th Amanda
delawicki Global News Montreal
turning now to the ongoing protests and
political unrest in Iran the regime's
Attorney General says the country's
so-called morality police which enforces
strict religious dress codes has been
shut down however that claim is now
being contradicted by Iran's own State
media saying the interior Ministry
oversees the force and has yet to
confirm that decision the Attorney
General also says Iran's Parliament and
Judiciary are also reviewing the
country's mandatory hijab laws violent
protests erupted back in September after
22 year old Masa amini died in police
custody after being detained for fair
failing to properly wear a hijab since
then more than 200 people have died
during anti-government demonstrations
[Music]
donation discrimination still ahead the
cost to change organ donor policies that
disqualify some Canadians over their
sexuality
a Saskatchewan man is demanding Health
officials reconsider the rules for organ
donations after he says his late
husband's tissues were disqualified
because of his same-sex marriage is kabi
malifaran reports Dwayne Belcourt
accuses Saskatchewan's health authority
of organ donation discrimination
I really think there's a double standard
going on and it's not fair Dwayne
Belcourt is not only mourning the death
of his husband but it's questioning why
his partner of over two decades wasn't
able to help others through organ
donation on August 30th Merle Duncan
died from stage four liver cancer
Belcourt received a call from the
Saskatchewan health authority regarding
organ and tissue donations and was first
told Duncan was a great candidate to be
a tissue donor an hour later sha called
again to clarify Duncan's relationship
with felcourt after she confirmed that
he had had sexual orders which was a man
after five after four or five years that
disqualified him all his tissues was
disqualified Belcourt says the policy is
discriminatory because they confirmed
Duncan was a viable donor prior to their
knowledge on his relationship you're
throwing away good viable tissue or
whatever you want to take from him
because he's a gay man and had sex with
a man and I asked him did you ask that
question of heterosexuals and the answer
was no Health Canada lists reasons that
may be used to determine a deceased
donor's risk of having a transmissible
disease including men who have sex with
men saying in a statement to global news
that it isn't law and allow for
flexibility and approach adding that
during the examination process should
include items that would determine
whether there is evidence of high risk
behavior the Sha tells global news that
Saskatchewan organ donation program is
following federal guidelines through a
statement the medical director of the
organ donation program says the intent
is not to discriminate explaining that
the ability to test donor tissues
quickly before a transplant is limited
their current guidelines are in place
based on research and clinical evidence
the sodp practices will evolve when
National standards evolve Belcourt says
the guidelines are outdated especially
given the recent changes made to blood
donation bans for gay men and he is
looking for answers they're advertising
that we can give our blood
but they won't take anything else
Belcourt says an equitable approach to
this greeting process is needed he says
he may consider taking legal action
after Consulting with the lawyer Kappy
Maly Theron Global News
[Music]
next a hopeful note the Vancouver Music
School Changing young lives in a
vulnerable community
[Music]
foreign
welcome back it's music to the ears of
children living in a vulnerable
Vancouver neighborhood St James Music
Academy is providing a program in the
downtown east side that's helping kids
to realize their potential Jay Durant
has that story
we are pretending that we are holding a
candy in your hand right Maya that's
music terminology these Young Beginners
can understand imagine that we have
bubbles under our arms for the past 15
years the St James Music Academy in
Vancouver's downtown east side has been
offering free lessons for kids grade 2
to 12. Elbow making music accessible for
children living in the neighborhood
having grown up in the downtown east
side myself I'm very familiar with a lot
of the different and unique challenges
that children can be exposed to living
here
they see them hold their instrument they
have this spark in their eye and they
are excited to show the world what it is
that they have to share
um
and then she has her thumb in the corner
these members of the junior program are
just starting out their musical journey
I would say I'm kind of good but it's a
lot to learn
I broke C by accident when I was trying
to tune it so here's a little tape
G
maybe it takes few months maybe it takes
few weeks it depends how they learn
these basic
but eventually they all work up the
courage to get on stage and perform with
the academy
ah we're next we're next you just relax
calm your body down
[Music]
sometimes playing alongside established
Canadian bands and musicians and once
even in front of the Dalai Lama
I have heard some of the graduates speak
about that they would have never been on
stages at the Commodore Ballroom or the
Orpheum and in return those students
were able to share with these musicians
something about their heart their life
and their Community gave them an inside
look into the real beauty that does
exist in this neighborhood that
sometimes gets overlooked generous
donors are giving these kids the chance
to learn to sing and play whether it
becomes a lifelong passion or just
something new to enjoy after school I
really hope to be like a songwriter or
like make people happy for being able to
play the violin
Jay Durant Global News
sounding great that is global national
for this Sunday night I'm Jeff Semple
tonight's your Canada is Bark Lake in
Berry's Bay Ontario thanks for watching
Donna Friesen will be back here with you
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]